hello rejects Greg here Brianna here
from the channel ahran graphics are and
graphics Aaron graphics my neighbor
downstairs loves to blast music whenever
I film it's very loud anyway yeah a few
months ago this live-action fan short
film came out Pokemon a great journey I
am interested in seeing this cuz you
know I don't keep up I don't really play
a Pokemon go but I did watch the entire
series up until he lost yeah at the
competition what was the competition
he's fighting to get to Final Four yeah
what city is he trying to get to not
Viridian City was it this is really
embarrassing I should tell this is very
embarrassing for you so embarrassing at
the indigo plateau okay damn it
I know these Pokemon I think it was
yellow pokemon yellow or maybe it was
blue like literally six months ago and I
couldn't remember that well we're gonna
watch this whatever this is
hopefully it is as awesome and I hope
you appreciate the background music
while we watch enjoy
[Music]
okay okay
I like it
okay it's like the Gameboy yeah I get it
whoa what the hell no way
whoa
[Music]
hey that was pretty cool
[Music]
here's a mustache
[Music]
this is Japan
[Music]
yet great exercise being a pokemon
trainer yeah
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
like this is mine
gross
[Music]
whoa okay yeah
oh sweet you're gonna poke it out
[Music]
such an epic face-off if they don't turn
twist their hat backwards I'm gonna be
really upset as you should be
doesn't look like it
what's that Pokemon call here fine sir
Oh
Charmander that's so sad my life
[Music]
nice
[Music]
they're like solids right now there's so
chill about
[Music]
it's like Ashton Moya little yeah
they're just gonna cut the gun making
out
[Music]
there it is
thank you
feels right whatever
[ __ ] down at chest great sign of
respect
Rock huh to train them misty was a
redhead oh my god oh he was Brock the
whole time
wait was that guy we were watching
brought the entire dr. Ben but he didn't
have these four eyes so I wasn't sure
yeah
cool
to be continued
there's gonna be another one I don't
know I don't know Breanna that would be
great
that's pretty cool no it's super cool I
mean what I really appreciate about it
like while the short films not perfect
in every capacity it's bigger than
anything I've ever done it was cool to
just see some of these Pokemon just like
brought to life in like a real world can
we talk about that why did squirtle have
like red rings around its eyes like I'm
like a crack at it
yeah some of the eyes of some of the
Pokemon looked a little depressed I get
that they're trying to make it like a
realistic animal cuz all animals have
that red ring around their eyes but I
was just like can they just be a little
bit cuter please yeah yeah like I know
this is Pokemon in real life but still I
want them to be the ideal version that's
true you know I was like squirtle see it
works for venusaur but I'm like
depending on the environment of where
the shots were of the Pokemon depending
on how the lighting and just the overall
myrin blended with where the creatures
are where venusaur isn't in the
beginning like that looked a real when I
first yes like holy [ __ ] they really
brought it to life just depending on
certain shots where you're like okay it
looks a little fake but still it's
pretty impressive that they were able to
still blend it in with the world pretty
pretty seamlessly you know I wish we got
to hear them talk a little bit though
you know I would you can understand how
that would be like well first of all
they looks like they're Italian
so or something like that and Italians
don't talk well for this film to have
the international appeal that it had
maybe it's better than it wasn't in
English and this is that's sure that it
wasn't spoken word and this is I saw an
uncharted fan film that was in I think
it was in Dutch that was really really
good
and when I looked down in the comments
all the Americans were like can you just
put in English please why are you
speaking different language and I was
like I'm embarrassed to be American yeah
I know they're working right now on a
live-action Pokemon film supposed to be
based off of like okay Pokemon yes yeah
the Pikachu detectives I'm not happy
I would much rather see like the ash
Ketcham story brought to life okay yeah
I would much rather see that like it's
gonna just be a kids movie Pikachu Pet
Detective like why do we need that yeah
why do we need that well I watch it
absolutely but like will I be happy
about it no I feel like like while the
cool thing is again we want to see the
Pokemon we I still feel that we would
need like a human character we could get
on board with it I feel like Ash's the
reason why the series and everything
sustained for so long as ash was a human
character we keep it but he was the
right age yeah exactly age of most of
the people playing the game which is why
things like Harry Potter did so well
yeah for some reason eleven-year-old
characters just makes a good character
yeah yeah exactly exactly yeah I mean
this game kind of look like they just
kind of look like a shamrock a little
bit more facial kind of look like Mario
and Luigi why just cuz they're Italian
you saw he's got the mustache he's got
the red hat I'm wondering like I'm glad
we saw all the starters obviously stoked
about that but haunter why Haunter like
of all Pokemon
I wasn't sure like why like was that
like just one of his favorites not sure
yeah sure although like Gyarados I
understand cuz that's like such a huge
epic Pokemon like you should totally do
that you saw a zoo but what what is with
Charmander there that's why another
moment where I'm like where's the cute
can you make him cute please not look
like a literal bearded dragon please
right doesn't he look derpy it's just
the the coloration of his eyes look a
little off like it's right I looks
completely bolded black and this is his
left eye has green bothers me or rather
that he just looks like a small bald guy
eyebrows I don't know where's his
personality he kind of looks like I've
ever seen the Super Mario Brothers movie
no he kind of looks like the Super Mario
Brothers Koopa that's the Koopa from the
Super Mario Brothers that's kind of what
I think it wouldn't see that I mean
still despite all that much love to the
creators this was obviously a work of
love and I think that they did a great
job
again again with this fan film you had
the perfect level of nostalgia meets
novelty and I really like that I just
want for their second trip for the
further a continuation of thing if they
do if they do go through with doing a
continuation that they do enhance more
of the passion behind the characters yes
like you don't have to have them talk
but they just seem kind of yeah they
just they seem so nonchalant during like
the train sequences yeah they're like
scientists about it yeah I want to see
like that passionate used in them when
they're actually doing stuff or like it
getting heated literally charmander like
evolved into a Charizard I was happy
about that I was happy about the lake
it's almost like a love letter -
Charmander as a starter which everybody
knows squirtle is the best starter but I
can understand why they went with
Charizard he has much more of a cooler
three evolutions so I'm really glad they
went with with that so that we could
eventually see the Charizard although
Blastoise would be a mega cool yeah I
like this shots when they were like
handheld - they made it look more real
when they're when they like the Pokemon
were in the shot so I thought that was
really neat yeah there's some like a
great stuff in here
I agree I agree aryn graphics make sure
to subscribe to our in graphics and
please make sure to subscribe to Briana
why it's gaming channel
wanted to say stranger gaming make sure
to subscribe it's strange rebel gaming
where there's a lot of fun Let's Plays
on there Breanna what are some Let's
Plays you've done recently didn't you
also do a video about Pokemon I did a
video about Pokemon go it was a detailed
review I am of the opinion that Niantic
has screwed up so badly that there's no
recovery but my friend Elissa was doing
it with me and she said that she still
plays and she thinks Niantic is doing a
good job it's a detailed review you
should go check it out your friend
Alyssa fun that's weird I introduced you
and Alyssa your friend my friend
yeah I never get invited to the parties
anymore no it's just a Breanna and
Alyssa party
you